[Music]  new at six we are learning more about a  proposal in carson city to remove racist  school mascots and place names assembly  bill 88 would require district change  mascots that use  names and logos associated with anything  that it  really cites discrimination the western  high school warriors for instance  would have to work with school officials  to change their name democrat  howard watts of las vegas says this also  applies  to 60 place names like lakes and  mountains  where we can get public feedback on  these things where we can learn about  the history  about why some people see them as  insensitive  and and come up with hopefully some  better options for some of these things  that are really hurtful the assemblyman  a unlv grad himself says he wanted to  see the school retire the  hay reb mascot which the school did in  january  he says unlv plans to keep the rebels  name